[Music]
okay we got to talk about the new music
what are you working on right now well I
have a new signal coming out in June so
on started I'm kicking off the summer
with the new song and then I'm finishing
the summer with the release of the album
summer of Shania member of Shania that's
how I feel and so it's going to be the
you know best summer ever for me it's
been such a long time since actually out
a studio album and I wrote the whole
album myself so it's a real statement of
independence created independence has
been something that I haven't had in a
really long time and it was really scary
taking that leap so I took it
the album's done and I feel really good
I feel relieved I feel good and first
single is just it's so optimistic and
hopeful regardless of how bad life can
get and I really needed that message I I
needed the whole album ahaab was really
fair like their five adjacent one it
totally was therapy and it worked
music is my is my third it's my drugs
songwriting especially more than
anything in music because it it's my
outlet my emotional outlet on of any
emotion whether it's sadness anger you
know happiness inspiration whatever it
is it all comes out best in my
songwriting I cannot wait to hear it
please tell me you're gonna play
something new at stagecoach I will yeah
I'll play the first thing go oh my gosh
so exciting I cannot wait is that gonna
be the first time anyone hears the
single yes that will be the debut of
this thing go yeah so how is prepping
for stagecoach going headlining Saturday
night so exciting it's going great I'm
you know it's going great I'm with you
know my band that I've had around for a
while now and
it's like home it feels like home
[Music]